You might not remember us but we met in the 90s.
We are members of Generation Y, as in yin yang, yo-yo.
Life moved a little slower.
Disks were square.
Desktop folders had personality.
Extra storage space was just a zipper away.
There is only one social network,...
...but most of your friends died of dysentery.
The only thing buzzing in your pocket was a pet.
Until that died too.
But at least the troll was still a friend.
Lunch was a puzzle, not a picture.
You were pumping jams, water, shoes.
You didn't have to worry about a news feed full of farm animals.
You were busy feeding wild animals.
A haircut didn't cost 60 dollars.
It cost four minutes.
You really had nothing to lose.
Unless, of course, you were playing for keeps.
The future was bright.
You grew up and so did we.